[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes et étudiants
l'université paris saclay donc voici
marion simon billeau minya et moi même
fatma dans le cadre de nos études nous
avons décidé de nous intéresser à
l'entrepreneuriat social et solidaire et
d'en expliquer les mécanismes
c'est pourquoi nous avons interviewé lui
seebach la cie offrande de l'application
toubous tour tant que touriste est une
application mobile qui permet à chacun
d'entre nous de s'engager concrètement
contre le gaspillage alimentaire
donc l'idée c'est de connecter les
commerciaux quartiers qui peuvent avoir
des invendus à la fin de la journée et
les utilisateurs les citoyens du
quartier qui vont du coup pouvoir passer
récupérer les invendus des commerçants à
la fermeture et donc se régaler à tout
petit prix et contribuer concrètement à
la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire
on connaît les définitions
gouvernementale de l'entrepreneur social
et solidaire qui sont en fait des
critères sur l'apport social de
l'innovation
mais quelles sont les particularités
d'une telle certain optimisme
d'une part en termes d'objectifs nous on
vise pas le développement financier de
notre entreprise en fait une autre pièce
principale c'est le nombre de repas
sauver c'est vraiment sur ça qu'on
s'appuie au quotidien une drive au
quotidien ce qu'on suit et pour moi en
fait à une vision tout à fait différente
de regarder le nombre de repas sauver ou
le chiffre d'affaires annuel de
l'entreprise juste visé le jeu fait plus
d'argent et plus d'argent j'ai vu
l'argent on voit plus trop l'intérêt par
contre à se dire que voilà que chaque
jour il ya des milliers de repas qui
sont sauvées grâce à ce qu'on fait au
quotidien ça ça veut vraiment dire
quelque chose et je pense que ça change
complètement la mentalité dans laquelle
tu viens au boulot et dans laquelle tu
tu te donnes à fond pour ce que tu fais
quoi et comment vois tu l'avenir de le
ss et de l'économie collaborative
assez assez assez énorme je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
se développe de plus en plus que des
problématiques à résoudre y en a des
tonnes et donc et que les gens ont
vraiment envie de s'y mettre aujourd'hui
que forcément avec le digital
il ya plein d'idées qui était difficile
à réaliser ya dix ans et qui aujourd'hui
sont parfaitement faisable
juste parce que tout le monde est
accessible juste par le patron d'un
smartphone dans nos tâches
je pense que de plus en plus
d'entreprises ont d'une part ajouté cet
aspect social et solidaire alors à leur
façon de travailler et que de plus en
plus d'entreprises vont se créer juste
là dessus et ça c'est plutôt assez
plutôt génial à imaginer et je pense
qu'on a de la chance de faire partie de
de ceux de ce mouvement et ce nouveau
monde qu'un train de se créer clairement
il ya eu la révolution industrielle et
puis à la révolution digitale et ça ça
permet et dans le monde solutions
positives pour la planète et pour la
société de se développer donc c'est
plutôt à très enthousiaste
[Musique]